this is crazy a White House spokesperson
has confirmed that President Barack
Obama and mr. Trump have been talking
regularly a big news story yeah and they
didn't give any more details than that
ladies and gentlemen this is incredible
we actually got a hold of the audio from
several phone calls don't giggle this is
real phone calls between President Obama
and president elect Trump and I think
it's my duty to share these with you
hello berrak it's true you know those
old photos you give at presidential
medals of Honor yeah can I get that
Betty what I want well there's a
conference I want to give one to Guy
Fieri and all the girls from the
godaddy.com commercial hello quick
question as I said what's your question
what is it some kind of a detail tab
expand as a country in Central Asia it's
bordered by China and Russia gotcha
follow-up question do we need it so what
do you have in the White House for
toilet paper
got no German ages up I don't know I
have to tell you that quilted or that is
terrific that's not really something I
know much about it is about it I'm gonna
fight back to New York for all of my
number two's hello now how do I make a
bill into a law
well first Congress has to pass the bill
no she's your daughter she's had right
she's a very attractive young lady your
dog you I can't leave the show put her
on the phone I think you should call if
German Chancellor Angela Merkel Angela
Merkel are you kidding me
I'll call her if I have a boner that
needs to go away
Oh Iraq it's dress the other question
the guys are the black rogues the
Supreme Court yeah they make my separate
states because they can't build
something that bad Kruger Oh boohoo
Oh Baba I think there's an al
eavesdropping on a girl very good at
that kidded I think I spy out is
listening to us Donald you're the one
who was telling the joke be quiet Obama
I'm calling you back to the secure line
above these file
[Applause]
you